so let's let's start off by talking
about Catholic education it's definitely
not now what it used to be like 50 years
ago and what it was like 50 years ago
wasn't what it was like a hundred years
ago there's been some amazing changes
we've got a lot of schools opened in the
last hundred years of the law schools
closed in the last hundred years and why
is that been the case well it has to do
with some of the developments that were
going on within an American Catholic
Church a lot of these are demographic
one of the things that was being you
know worried about was how to carry out
Americanization with in Catholic schools
Catholic schools develop into an entire
network an entire system that provides
an alternative to what where did you go
if you are going to Catholic school if
you were a Catholic it the mines hang
out on the corner I put you in public
school why did Catholics me they have
internal schools yeah actually the they
really wanted to get as many Catholic
kids's non-catholics wanted to get as
many Catholic kids as possible into
public schools so that they could do
something important with them yeah i
would think my parents summer kids
Catholic schools like so they can learn
about very Legend and what
yeah now notice it was not allowed to be
taught today in public schools although
actually you can teach about religion in
public schools the Supreme Court
distinguishes between teaching religion
and teaching about religion back at the
time that Catholic schools became a
going concern they were teaching about
religion in schools but they were
teaching about it from the Protestant
perspective so the King James Bible
might actually be a textbook in many
classes there were other you know
textbooks that they were using you know
about state American history where
Catholics would be left out or you know
demonized also mermans also you know
other other groups as well not to
mention you know atheists theists for a
long time so they wanted to be an
alternative to the public school system
because the public school system was
probably anti-catholic if they they
wanted to get as many of these kids not
into Catholic schools but into public
schools so that they could get the
Catholicism out of them that was the
view of many of the educational
reformers of the time whether Protestant
more secular so the Catholic school
systems develop and they end up doing a
couple really important things one is if
you have not you know ng cooking of
course providing a lot of people decent
education nowadays we tend to associate
Catholic schools with with excellence
but that's more I would say a mark of
how public schools have declined then
plus we got the schools being to the
grave Hogan arson in stellar yeah so
they educate they also carry out
something we might call a standard
experience and your book talks in this
term about the Catholic ghetto and they
don't mean it in a pejorative term like
let me say that something is is ghetto
meaning that it's you know made up on
the spot or not as good it's a knockoff
of things like that that's a very
contemporary term and they don't mean it
necessarily in the sense of slums a
little kid a lot of Catholics did live
in pretty bad neighborhoods my amounts
of interesting stories about what it was
like growing up in Chicago for what it
meant by Tony mojetto was that the
Catholics had their own sets of
institutions in large part certainly now
centered around the Catholic schools
which would provide a kind of world 11
Catholic commentator talks about what it
was like back then and that's even
before my generation or even some of
your grandparents generation so it would
just talk about the Catholic experiences
here comes everything because everybody
that you would know on your block would
probably be Catholic or you know the odd
Protestant or Jew or free thinker and
you probably all went to the same school
and tended to you know come to think and
see the world in the same ways like your
book says there's there's reasons for
this the middle decades of the 19th
century were dominated by the need for
rapid expansion of the the school
systems to accommodate the flood tide of
Catholic immigration so what happens
when you expand something very quickly
we often want to think that that
promotes a lot of creativity and more
institutions you have Wow more diversity
of thought you're going to have
everybody can like find their niche is
that really the case more often it does
lead to kind of standardization a kind
of leveling everybody ends up seeing
things the same way so your book talks
about that is being a key thing it
became required by the
third plenary Council Baltimore that
every school system every parish had to
provide a Catholic school so this really
made parish is important central to to
the experience that's not the case
anymore is it that every parish has its
own school the Catholic schools in this
area just what really they underwent
another assessment of which ones ought
to close it's about a year ago some of
them made the cut some of them didn't
ones that didn't they protested that
then they got closed why you know why
did they do that well because there
wasn't enough population to support them
drawing resources away from the diocese
this was the opposite of that in this
case they were saying if you have a
parish you have to have a school because
you've got to have some way of providing
all this to those kids that all those
parents those church-going parents are
making you know putting into your midst
and so your book talks about the role of
the parish it talks about whether they
compare liturgical activity what they
mean by this is that the parish becomes
a center for all sorts of things besides
the mass all sorts of other devotions
and organizations and clubs you know
what are the sort of organizations today
there's very few that it survived
certainly very few than ever that are
attracting the young one of the sort of
organizations you associate with
Catholics and not with priests or nuns
with ordinary Joe's and Josephine's
engaged Catholic life who are the people
who put on the fish fries for example
it's not the priest out there you know
flipping baskets of fish making fries
can't get the plates they might put in
some time you know but they're pretty
busy a lot of the priests currently a
lot of math to do like two or three
parishes who are the people that are
doing these sort of volunteer activities
yeah now the Knights of Columbus would
be an example of what they're talking
about as a you know parish based and
that's a bigger organization is parish
base you know the guys in your group
they recruit from within the parish
there's all sorts of organizations like
that once you scratch the surface many
of them are pretty old and old in the
sense that they have many older members
and in comparison to younger other
organizations would be you know athletic
organizations literary organizations if
you you want to for example Chesterton
is an important Catholic writer there's
a Chesterton society that meets here in
Poughkeepsie I'd never go on I'm a big
Chester to the fan but you know schedule
nothing makes it so but there are people
who meet together and not all of us are
in the Catholic but you can bet that
most of them will be it's probably gonna
be hosted by parish they talk about a
lot of observances like novenas
exposition of the the host saying the
rosary all these sorts of things people
getting together
that that's all part of this this big
you know totalizing parish life whether
they're referring to now your book also
talks about what supported this the
emphasis on devotional piety and
ecclesiastical Authority continues an
extensive and centralized institutional
network in which Catholic schools play a
rapidly growing role this is what they
talk about is ghetto culture ghetto
again because it tends to isolate
Catholics intense have become its own
sort of separate world so Catholics may
engage with non-catholics say in the
marketplace or where else in work in the
army but for the most part to people
that they know on associate what they're
going to be other Catholics one cost of
this was what one commentators call the
dirty little secret of great Vatican to
Catholicism and impose uniformity of
thought and practice I'm going to skip
on a little bit your book does also talk
about a film which if we're going to
talk about culture cuter culture where
all the Catholics have in film anybody's
for the film buff those are film history
you know that rating system at the mm
films not really followed much anymore
can watch whatever you want like a
netflix or things like that right you
know gee anybody can go to g movie PG
pretty much anyone can go to a PG movie
2 pg-13 are artists or the big dividing
line right that's supposed to be able to
go into an r movie if you're like
unless you are accompanied by a parent
or guardian or whatever but acts you
know that's the dirty stock definitely
got it or now it's NC you know 17 what's
all that about how did that happen
that's not the you know that's not that
at the beginning of the code the code
developed over time Catholics that have
made it part of that if you ever watched
what they call pre-code Hollywood movies
they were pretty racy people came up
with some wild stuff in the 20s and
Catholics reactive against that you know
if Protestants were the ones who are
driving prohibition Catholics were the
ones who are primarily driving having
some sort of restriction system for for
the movies trying to make the movies
more wholesome less you know less about
all these other dirty perverse you know
violent things so there's on the one
hand a kind of restrictive pneus on the
other hand there's also a lot of
involvement of Catholics in the movie
business and there's this emergence of
the new film genre with the book called
the hero priests Catholic priests were
now depicted uniformly not only as
morally flawless but it's handsome
affable muscular and even in the case of
Bing Crosby as musical he did a lot of
you know movies like that so you got
these two sides and he's continued until
about the 1960s again what happens in
1960s what did what happens in film in
the 1960s and 70s nobody's a film buff
sure nobody's really in the movies genre
of horror movies for example flourishes
you would not see the exorcist which is
a 1970s movie being done in nineteen
forty to fifty that's something
that happens after that what else other
realms of cultural and intellectual life
what we see leading up to that akin to
and then definitely after Vatican to the
kind of opening up a flower of Catholic
culture Catholic intellectual life
evilyn wad Graham Greene Francis Moria
those are those are some key novelists
if you haven't read people like green
and law you ought to their great writers
if you want it you know if you want to
see what these people were actually
thinking about the sort of themes that
they were focused on there was relevant
today as they were back then Flannery
O'Connor I think probably put a few be
probably read her or at least a story by
her in your high school lit classes
juices in a southern Catholic you start
seeing a lot of other things happening
in philosophy and theology in plays and
literature and and there's also a lot of
people within those groups we're very
critical of the institutional Catholic
trip Graham Greene is a great example of
that Catholic education undergoes some
major transformations beginning in the
60s so so what changes again demography
really drives this what happens to
people when they become more affluent do
they have more kids or less kits as
there is your fortunes increase why less
time to have sex is that it
that's a big thing right there yeah so
children are born later fewer of them if
you don't want to be you know it
children actually cost quite a bit of
money so one way to not be pores don't
have a whole bunch of kids just the app
I had some actually tend to booze things
but there were other things going on too
birth control in the in the form of the
contraceptive pill became widely
available in the 1960s and that
dramatically affected birth rates now if
you have all these Catholic schools that
you've built all over the place and you
don't have more cap the kids being born
you have some but it has it's not
growing and growing and growing what
happens but can't have all them all
those schools you can have all those
kids in schools but you don't need quite
so many you can add to that to that from
the 1960s on we see a dramatic drop in
vocations at least in the United States
to these these orders that carried on a
lot of the work in Catholic schools I'll
put it to you this way when I was so I'm
20 years older than all of you when I
was in Catholic school in high school
the nuns that we had were all old and
some of them died while i was in school
doesn't sound nice i know but it's a
fact you know why did they why was that
happening because they were the ones who
were actually doing the teaching they
weren't getting a new new nuts there
were very few young nuns I think the
youngest one was probably 60 now that
was in my generation for Catholic
schools in your generation it's almost
all late each errs most of our teachers
were
call a teacher that means non-religious
we had a few priests bunch of nuns and
fewer when I left then and when I came
in in the previous generation and they
still had quite a few the younger ones
but they weren't getting a lot of
replacements now what's the best thing
about having nuns from an institutional
perspective if you're the one running
the school what's the best thing about
having nuns or monitor the priest
teacher yeah well hopefully peers
there's some horror stories you know
about how mean the nuns were some of
them are actually true so it's not that
although you would hope that's the case
right think about it in purely economic
terms yeah yeah where you can pay them
very very little that's part of what
allowed a lot of Catholic schools to be
able to offer a wide you know range to a
lot of different students the fact that
they had a labor source that because
they have this religious vocation would
be involved in that late teachers and
Catholics will still in general make
less than than public school teachers
but they make a lot of nothing and so
that makes it harder to keep schools
open as well your book talks about the
abandonment of many inner-city parishes
many parochial schools lack their
traditional demographic base as
neighborhood's changed to become less
and less Catholic a lot of Catholic
schools but what are we doing here and
interestingly in the inner cities the
majority of the students in Catholic
schools are not Catholic what are they
who's who's sending their kids to
Catholic schools if they're now Catholic
yeah you don't send your children to
public schools
which is cheaper yeah we're like we're
back to it's an alternative to the
public schools so it is used in
particular in you know poor
neighborhoods by african-american
students whose parents like the fact
that Catholic schools have same dress
codes discipline good academic standards
in comparison to you know some of the
other local schools so that that's a
major change as well your book then sort
of brings things to it close by top
going back again to talk about
intellectual life and they turn out this
process this is kind of a good place to
finish up in the end of time before
Vatican too there was this opening
before Vatican's who happened towards
greater intellectual investigation
towards recovering what was there it
says enhances and enhanced historical
consciousness began to emerge as
Catholic resources increase
substantially so Gothic Revival
architecture would be be a visible form
of this Gregorian chant coming back in
singer you know not something that's
easy to relate to Pontifical Institutes
of medieval studies miotto mysm all of
that focus on the medieval in that case
and a very sort of truncated version of
the medieval after Vatican 2 happens
after there's this emphasis on going
back to the sources Catholic scholarship
just opens up that becomes a major force
on the intellectual seen in part because
they're going back to all these you know
Church figures that had often been
neglected say Augustine you know as
opposed to
Thomas Aquinas there is the founding of
the Catholic biblical association of
america american catholic biblical
scholars begin to be taken seriously not
just by Catholics but by Protestants and
this is how we reach the sort of stink
we are at today where you have you know
major research institutions which are
Catholic institutions like you know
Notre Dame like Georgia some people
would say that they've lost their
Catholic identity but there's still you
know a lot of people there who are
working in a distinctively Catholic mode
who are focused on you know this is
pretty broad history and it's fertilized
Protestant scholarship which it's also
drawn upon theirs but a lot of remember
we talked about ecumenism and dialogue
that happens at a scholarly level in
terms of thought and culture as well as
just getting together with you know
people from different religions and
shooting the breeze so that's a good
place I think to bring our story of the
captain's pretty much to applause